y bueno una vez dado lo que ya vimos
vamos a ver si podemos resolver está
derivada implícita mucho más fácil tengo
x menos y elevado al cuadrado es igual a
x menos 1 así que apliquemos el operador
derivada a ambos lados de la ecuación y
que voy a obtener bueno la primera parte
la voy a resolver por la regla de la
cadena porque tengo una función elevada
al cuadrado y por lo tanto la regla de
la cadena lo que dice es baja el
exponente entonces vamos a poner aquí el
2 después ponemos tal cual la función y
le bajamos 1 el exponente dos veces x
menos a la potencia dos menos uno que es
uno pero como es la potencia uno ya no
lo voy a escribir y después dice la
regla de la cadena ahora deriva lo que
está dentro con respecto a x la derivada
de x con respecto a x es 1 y la derivada
de ella con respecto a x es justo lo que
queremos es la derivada de ella con
respecto a x muy bien esto es del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación todo esto fue
por la regla de la cadena
esta es la derivada d
x elevada al cuadrado con respecto a x
menos con respecto a x menos estos por
la regla de la cadena y esto que está
aquí de rojo es la derivada de x menos
con respecto a x recuerden la regla de
la cadena
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa del lado derecho esto va a ser
igual a la derivada con respecto a x de
x lo cual es 1 y la derivada con
respecto a x de ye pues es la derivada
de llegó en respecto a x justo lo que
queremos y después la derivada con
respecto x de una constante se va
recuerden que las derivadas de una
constante no aparecen entonces ya no hay
necesidad de ponerlo y ahora sí vamos a
tratar de despejar a la derivada de ya
con respecto a x para eso lo primero que
voy a hacer es empezar a distribuir
todas estas multiplicaciones que tengo
aquí tengo 2 que multiplica a x menos y
es lo mismo que 2 x menos 2 james y esto
a su vez multiplica a uno menos las
derivadas de y con respecto a x entonces
va a ser este por este y este por éste
2 x 2 x 1 pues es 2 x 2 2 x menos oye
ahora tengo 2 x menos 2 ya que
multiplica a menos la derivada de ye con
respecto a x como tengo un signo menos
lo que voy a hacer es cambiarla y la x
del lugar me voy a quedar 2 james menos
2x por la derivada de ye con respecto a
x ojo cambie a la y l x del lugar por el
signo menos que teníamos acá arriba y
bueno del lado derecho no queda uno más
la derivada de ella con respecto a x
ahora lo que quiero hacer es despejar a
la derivada de que con respecto a x por
lo tanto de este lado voy a restar menos
2 x menos 2 james y si lo hago de un
lado también lo tengo que hacer es de
otro lado menos 2 x menos 2 james para
que se cancelen estos dos términos y de
este lado pues tengo que poner lo mismo
menos 12 x menos 2 muy bien ahora bien
de este lado derecho tengo la derivada
de ye con respecto a x positiva y la voy
a pasar del lado izquierdo con signo
contrario por lo tanto la tengo que
restar de ambos lados de la ecuación y
me queda menos
con respecto a equis y aquí también
menos la derivada de ella con respecto a
equis y ahora sí voy a hacer las
correspondientes operaciones tanto del
lado izquierdo como del lado derecho y
2x menos 2 ya que suma y 2x menos 2 ya
que restan se van se hacen 0 desaparecen
aquí tengo 2 menos 12 x menos 1 que
multiplica a la derivada de ella con
respecto a x y eso lo voy a escribir
este menos es menos 1 por lo tanto me
queda dos menos 12 x menos 1 todo eso
multiplicando a la derivada de ella con
respecto a x 2 y menos 2 x menos 1 todo
esto multiplicando la derivada de ella
con respecto a x ahora qué pasa del otro
lado tengo esta derivada de ye con
respecto a x menos la derivada de ella
con respecto a x se van también y lo que
se queda es un 11 menos 2x y un menos x
menos me va a dar más un +2 james aquí
me queda menos x menos me queda más 2
- 2x y este 1 de acá arriba 1 y ahora sí
si lo que quiero es despejar a la
derivada de ella con respecto a x voy a
pasar todo esto que está multiplicando
dividiendo entonces me queda la derivada
de ye con respecto a x va a ser igual y
ya por fin acabe justo lo que quería la
derivada de ye gon respecto x esto es
igual a bueno del lado derecho tengo 2
menos 12 x + 1 y hay que dividirlo entre
dos y menos 2 x menos 1 y hemos acabado